in this video we will look at an
extremely important concept related to
polynomials think about it they can
actually be just two broad categories of
polynomials the first category which has
just one variable and the second one
which has more than one variable that's
it these are the only two possibilities
an example of the first type would be 6
X raised to 5 plus 2x squared minus 7x
plus 9 this polynomial has just one
variable which is X an example of the
second type would be 5x y cubed plus 17
XY plus 9 Y squared plus 9 this has two
variables x and y which makes it fall
into the second category so what about
these two categories why did we form
them it is for the concept we will look
at in this video the degree of the
polynomial in the first category where
we have just one variable the degree is
the largest exponent of that variable
here v is the largest exponent which
tells us that the degree is 5 the degree
of this polynomial is 5 let's look at a
second example in this category 21 x
plus 6 x cubed plus 7 plus x squared in
the first term the degree of x is 1 in
the second term the degree of x is 3 and
in the last term it's 2 3 becomes the
largest exponent of the variable and
that's why the degree of this polynomial
is 3 is it any different in the second
case yes slightly different in the
second case for each term we add the
exponents of each variable in it how
will it work out for the first example
remember we have to look at each term
individually consider the first term 5
XY cubed we had to add the exponents of
variable in it the exponent of X is 1
and the exponent of Y is 3 so for the
first term we consider the power to be 1
plus 3 which is 4 now we come to the
second term there are two variables x
and y and each of them have an exponent
equal to 1 adding the exponents we
consider the exponent of this term to be
1 plus 1 which equals 2 in the third
term we have just one variable its
exponent will just be 2 and as we have
no variables in the last term its
exponent will be 0 remember we are
looking at exponents of variables the
exponent of variables of the last term
is 0 and the largest of these becomes
the degree the degree of this polynomial
is 4 which is the highest amongst these
here's our last example 7x z plus 10
plus 3 Z cubed y plus 19 y raise to 4 we
have four terms here in the first term
the sum of exponents of X and Z is 2 in
the second case since we have no
variables the exponent is 0 in the third
term it's 3 plus 1 which equals 4 and in
the fourth term as well the exponent is
4 4 is the highest amongst these four
terms
hence the degree of this polynomial is 4